beaucoup de gens croient que le
journalisme ça consiste à écrire un truc
sur un coin de table et avoir un peu de
culot c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça tout de même
il doit y avoir une raison mystérieuse
qui pousse les gens vers le journalisme
parce que dans le journalisme on trouve
d'habitude
des milieux extrêmement divers on trouve
des avocats des médecins des professeurs
pourquoi ne sont-ils ni avocats ni
médecin ni professeur et pourquoi elles
sont-ils devenus journalistes il doit y
avoir une raison ils attendent des
journalistes quelque chose de plus moi
je regrette pas du tout est-ce que vous
pensez que dans la carrière c'est en
général ce qui se produit c'est à dire
que les journalistes ne regrettent pas
d'avoir choisi le journalisme
oui dans l'ensemble dans l'ensemble les
conversations que j'ai eu avec mes
confrères mes camarades de journal dans
l'ensemble une regrette pas d'avoir
choisi le journalisme c'est peut-être
aussi le besoin
de dire quelque chose de dire quelque
chose qui n'aurait pas pu dire dans le
métier qu'ils exercent
le peut-être je schématise beaucoup mais
c'est valable surtout
ces dernières années le désir
d'apprendre quelque chose au genre moi
je considère que il y a chez chaque
journaliste
un prof d'une certaine manière est-ce
qu'il y a une crise du journalisme alors
une crise des journaux je crois que oui
je n'ai pas tous les chiffres dans la
tête mais il semble que d'une manière
générale en ce qui concerne par exemple
les grands journaux il y a une baisse de
tirage depuis un certain nombre d'années
presque quotidienne et une partie de la
précept de Madère enfin elle s'en plaint
tout au moins il y a j'ai l'impression
moins de noms très connus dans le
journalisme
on connaît les journaux mais il y a
moins de vedettes il y a une
stérilisation beaucoup plus limitée du
journalisme que me semble-t-il
avant guerre sur deux on peut y entrer
je crois relativement facilement mais on
en sort aussi vite c'est un des
avantages en même temps des grands
inconvénients de qui est beaucoup de
gens croient que le journaliste ça
consiste à écrire un truc sur un coin de
table et avoir un peu de culot c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça tout de
même un journal dans une certaine mesure
et forcer de tenir compte de la
sensibilité de ses lecteurs et cette
cette attitude du journal Eugénie sur
les journalistes qui doivent parfois
mesurer certaines de la réaction
personnelle par rapport au public en
tenant compte du public si ce sentiment
allait à l'encontre de la
du goût du public et bien vous auriez un
des journaux qui ne se vendraient plus
et tout de même un des points les plus
importants pour un journal c'est de se
vendre il y a des photos de lui quand il
était dans l'armée allemande
ah oui je les ai vu elles ont paru ici
dans un hebdomadaire je sais plus lequel
il y a une photo de lui en jeunesse
hitlerienne
alors je pense que maintenant on doit
pouvoir l'obtenir à un prix quand même
meilleur
il faudrait que tu vois ici d'où le
classement de la famille d'Angleterre
l'ancien crochet placement de la famille
agaka Dany Saval de Frank Sinatra la
famille
Carole tienne Mansfield les 50 de boîte
du général de Gaulle c'est très
important également
je crois que votre spécialité c'est tout
de même la chronique mondaine
enfin à 18 ans donc je connais pas mal
de monde à Paris et c'est plus facile de
m'envoyer moi à des réceptions parce que
je connais les gens et que je peux
mettre un nom sur eux
et en parler quelqu'un qui ne les
connaît pas par exemple un acteur dont
le film sort dans la semaine à des
chances de sortir dans le journal parce
qu'on en parle parce que les gens s'y
intéressent ils vont voir le film on a
parlé du film alors il est pas sage à
Paris on interview et les gens sont
curieux de savoir qui est cette personne
ce qu'elle fait comment elle s'habille
ou elle habite quels sont ses habitudes
de vie etc qu'est-ce qu'on appelle le
forcing en termes de métier je l'ai fait
on fait ça très rarement mais c'est très
désagréable c'est à dire quand les gens
refusent de vous parler ou de vous voir
les obliger à vous rencontrer par
exemple
une personne sur quoi est obligé d'être
obligé très souvent de perdre du forcing
c'est la Callas
parce qu'elle est très capricieuse alors
elle change d'avis et puis même quand
elle dit non on essaye quand même de la
voir ce qui m'est arrivé l'année
dernière alors on envoie un malheureux
faire ce qui s'appelle une planque c'est
à dire qu'il attend il attend devant
l'entrée d'une maison ou d'un théâtre la
sortie de la personne photographier
et malheureusement il arrive très
souvent qu'il attendent toute une
journée en vain et que à bout
enfin vers 8 ou 9 heures du soir ils
partent boire quelque chose et qu'à ce
moment-là la personne sorte mais par
exemple le premier portage que j'ai fait
dans ce journal je m'en souviendrai
toute ma vie c'était d'aller voir des
parents d'hôtesse de l'air qui
habitaient en dans un faubourg de Paris
et où j'ai failli faire assassiner parce
que le père de l'hôtesse que j'avais été
voir avait bu beaucoup parce qu'il était
il avait beaucoup de chagrins et il est
descendu sur moi avec un couteau de
cuisine à la main et je suis rentrée
Dardar au journal en disant je quitte ce
journal le père de cette malheureusement
personne qui avait été tué dans cet
accident de Boeing avait perdu
complètement la raison il disait comment
est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui peut
venir demander des photos après une
épreuve pareil enfin il me courir après
autour de la table et je trouvais plus
la porte de sortie je suis parti en
courant
mise au point
aujourd'hui vas-y continue
est-ce que vous êtes venu voir
bien j'insiste aujourd'hui contre Clark
c'est ça que nous sommes en effet mais
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
particulièrement vous avez un angle
quelque chose
et puis alors ensuite je pense que si
jazzy gagne on va le suivre on va on va
suivre sa vie enfin ce soir je crois
qu'il doit aller dîner avec Clark et on
le suivra on essaiera de faire son dîner
parce qu'il sera tard
il me dérange absolument pas
ça m'arrive parfois oui
des égoïstes disons pour moi les
journalistes égoïstes se sont ceux qui
essaient de s'approcher le plus loin
possible de la du personnage quoi vous
savez quand j'étais dans un quotidien
enfin Midi Libre c'était différent parce
que d'abord
je faisais tout si vous voulez je
m'envoyait je faisais mon papier je
faisais mes photos en même temps
si vous voulez j'avais l'impression de
faire davantage puisque je faisais tout
moi-même
mais
en province je pense que
on peut pas vraiment faire son métier à
fond et est-ce qu'une femme qui est
journaliste éprouve des difficultés plus
grandes qu'un homme à arriver à
justement faire un papier et à se
réaliser
je crois que les femmes effectivement
ont beaucoup plus de difficultés dans ce
métier c'est pas un métier de femme
mais
ce réaliser entièrement et elles ont
beaucoup plus d'obstacles que les hommes
certainement lesquels
d'abord des obstacles de physique enfin
une femme n'a pas la résistance physique
d'un homme
déjà première chose
et puis
une femme et davantage menée par ses
sentiments si vous voulez ce que souvent
on est obligé de laisser de côté en
travaillant
un homme aussi a des sentiments
est-ce qu'il doit les laisser de côté
parce qu'il est journaliste et homme
je crois pas qu'il doit les laisser de
côté je crois qu'il les laisse de côté
parce que c'est un homme
automatiquement notre métier nous amène
à connaître certaines personnes étaient
certains lieux certains pays et on
pourrait parler de Brigitte Bardot
est-ce que vous sentez
en face de Brigitte Bardot qui a une
renommée mondiale est-ce que vous sentez
sur un pied d'égalité absolument ce que
vous travaillez mais absolument parce
que Brigitte Bardot c'est un mythe c'est
un mythe pour les gens qui ne la
connaissent pas mais ceux qui la
connaissent c'est une femme comme une
autre c'est c'est une jeune femme
charmante gentille agréable c'est une
très bonne copine et principalement elle
principalement elle elle a envie qu'on
la traite elle le dit souvent j'ai envie
que mes amis me traitent comme bruit et
non pas comme Brigitte Bardot c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'elle aime les animaux
je sais pas si vous êtes au courant elle
adore les animaux parce que elle dit les
animaux eux ne savent pas que je suis
connu et quand ils ont un bon regard
pour moi je sais que c'est pour moi ce
n'est pas pour Brigitte Bardot c'est les
animaux ne sont pas mystifiés le journal
de droite écrit des choses pour
son public
il fait un reportage en fonction du
rédacteur en chef qui lui en général
politiquement et disons à droite si son
journal est de droite ou à gauche et son
journal let gauche et il écrit des
choses pour son public parce que si on
dit pour ne pas les décevoir et c'est
rare de voir un journaliste de gauche
passé pendant un journal de droite et un
journal de un journaliste de droite
passer dans un truc de gauche c'est
assez rare pour les grandes mutations je
suis d'accord mais il y a de petites
mutations on peut passer d'un journal de
d'extrême gauche un journal de gauche et
à ce moment-là changer un petit peu
d'optique sans changer complètement de
personnalité mais est-ce que c'est parce
que on a changé de journal qu'on a
changé d'optique ou assez c'est parce
que l'on a changé d'optique on a changé
de journal
[Musique]